I'm Councillor Paul Williams from the Waimakariri District Council and I'm here to
tell you a few of the facts that's
happened from the wrap up of the
November council meeting.
We've approved
funding for the Southbrook main trunk
line that's coming into Rangiora
from the South Brook sewage system to
improve the capacity of the sewerage for Rangiora.  The councillors decided to
organise this over the school holidays, so there was not so much disruption to the
Southbrook schools and preschool in
the area.
The Council passed the adoption of the
Waimakariri Accessible Strategy and
this will give wee bit more access for
disabled people around Waimakariri and
improve hopefully quite a lot of the
problems they're having in the area so
that's been passed in this council
meeting which is a good thing.
The council have deferred payments for the
Riding For The Disabled, which the
Council has loaned them some funds
to buy prefab unit for the club rooms
and they've now deferred the payments so
the club have a wee bit more time to
make payments to the council to
2020, so council looking after them as
best we can.
In 1892 there was a gravel pit area
that was designated for the local
council then, and the Waimakariri Council
now have just gone invested that as a
reserve for utilities which will give a
position to put a new water bore for
Oxford community for the future planning
of Oxford.
So that was a bit of a wrap-up
what's happened on this particular
council meeting in November and the
biggest meeting, probably of the year, is
going to be coming up in December where
some of the real nitty gritty important bits and pieces will be brought up.
I believe the four courts and the
three-bin system will be discussed on
that time so that will be interesting to
look forward to.